good morning everyone
I'm so sorry for the delay but not
really that sorry because it wasn't my
fault we're running about 10 minutes
late but I will make it up to because
this is about to be a three-hour [ __ ]
show right here because my co-host is
someone I've been waiting to get back in
the golden throne and he is finally here
it is Brian Kelly the points guy it's so
good to have you back like we have so
much to talk about like I can't even
waste time right now like not talking
about what we need to be talking about
so Brian Kelly if you guys don't know
him get your head out of your ass he is
the founder creator owner operator of
the points guy calm you are the points
guy but now you just go by Brian right
my mom calls me TPG so do I you and your
me and your mom you'd love my mom
amazing yeah I'm gonna can't believe we
have a same nickname now I feel like I
shouldn't call it whatever but TBT is
also like friend of grunge and and what
most people don't know about you which
is why I'm most excited to have you here
it's like you're just so dynamic yes sir
this businessman flying all around the
world to your important conferences but
you're also like a big housewives fan
you are a friend of Bethenny's wife's
historian is what I call myself that's a
good one
friend of Bethany which is just the
highest honor one can reach and just
all-around
fun-loving gay which is like I just
think you need more more time we need to
get to know Bryant more than we need to
get to know TPG you know oh my god we
opened up for questions for you
we got literally some of the most
specific questions I took most of them
some of them were like how do I refine
it like just a little too specific but
do people just come up to you and
they're like hey you know I have this
credit card like do they just like throw
their problems at you it's funny in real
life people they don't ask me questions
they want to say well I use my points
and I did this and people I think are
just so excited yeah and I'm proud and
it makes it easier for me especially
when I'm hungover all I have to do is
listen
but yeah via DM we get so many questions
and so yeah I was actually on my delayed
car ride here like brushing up on
information because I saw some of them
come in oh my god they're insane and
also you're so tall to be to move up our
sign so that caused a further delay just
you know unexpected but that's live
television people you never know what to
expect
so we before we jump in to the news that
you need to know today and we're gonna
get all the Brian's questions answered
we have to talk about
day night because TPG bestowed the honor
upon me of giving his extra ticket to
the VMAs to me and I just want to say I
feel like we really maximized our
experience it's like we went in in the
mindset and by the way we started our
night off you guys have to know what was
the restaurant called salt Bay's rescue
shirt at doll dot whatever it is the
salt bag the guy his restaurant in New
York very rich like I'm looking but it's
one big Instagram thirst trustee and
they um you know like we don't Instagram
unless were paid but there were so many
times where I was going it's like I
wanted like the it was so funny the
black ice like randomly they were poor
black ice into the containers and then
we're just cool over the ball I'm really
good everyone they had like a step and
repeat yes ten foot mural and everyone
was doing his pose and there's hashtags
like written on the windows it was so
thirsty but the food was good it was
luscious and good service but just watch
out for the tipping situation oh my god
okay so homegirl gave me the bill and I
was like signing it and she was like oh
he actually paid for because he always
pays me every two days and he just
wasn't important she was bringing me to
the VMAs like I had to you know just I
let you pay yeah he did and so the lady
I paid for drinks at the VMAs so
literally I just throw away she's like
oh by the way there's 18% tip included
I'm like wow as she's signing the tip I
had already written and it was it like
it was expensive and I doubled the tip
very Miami moment it was just like what
that's like not a thing here or like
ever unless like on vacation and she
just said it like as a throwaway comment
I'm like oh thank you for telling me
like she could have not told me and like
she would have you know I'm sure you
still tipped her right are you supposed
to know no oh my god stop don't give me
a bit about tipping everyone is always
giving me a pen I never know it's a hard
interaction I just had breakfast this
morning at Gramercy Park Tavern they
have because I'm really successful like
I do breakfast and actually that's where
we had dinner the other night
and yes tipping is included I think
tipping should be included everywhere
but then they don't actually get it
right well Patel but they do but then
you feel like they don't
I still feel well I'm a I'm a big tipper
Oh No thank you and I really want
reward someone who like goes out of
their way to be like kind and I just
feel like it's automatically assumed
everyone's gonna get the same like you
know me like moderate level it's kind of
like in Europe yeah yeah oh yeah what
are your thoughts on Europe I'm not a
fan I'm going to Munich on Sunday I love
Europe
you do yeah first of all I'm just we
couldn't be more different Europe is
very diverse first of all is it it's a
continent not a country
I knew that yeah no I live totally live
in London is that the only place you
think it would live outside of New York
I could yeah I mean I yeah I'd never
really want to live one place I like
what you did sing it up yeah you don't
do you ever get like tired from
travelling it's awesome travelling like
it's like it's addictive like I not for
me yeah that's the anti affect like I
get off my meds between here in
Nashville every time I go on a plane i
text cmeg emic this is my itinerary how
do I get on a lay flat first-class bed
for five dollars and he's like you can
which is very sorry it's like I'm taking
Amtrak to Boston which one has the life
left that they don't wait VMAs so we
went to the restaurant and I really
enjoyed it I have to say I want to give
it a two thumbs up and then we walked
over to a Radio City which was I was
surprised that it was there cuz it's
like kind of a smaller smaller yeah but
I still feel like when we walked in I
was really surprised at how like they're
just traditional like theater stage
really like was elevated to it like that
before
yeah and they had like that thing go up
and down every time I performer started
no and I think we really just threw
ourselves into it we didn't take
ourselves too seriously and we happened
to be seated right next to the exit
where our kicker sees our purposes being
media we were standing by the store that
people celebrities were going in and out
of backstage like every time they would
sit like when they were up for an award
they would go sit in front but then like
when they don't want to like say like
Travis Scott before him they would go
backstage and we were right by that
drawer so cardi B most people went back
and forth but who stayed there the whole
time to be noticed captain Tandy the
other one the male Wow nope the other
one rod oh yes I was being thirst
monster and you know what I'd like to
have the VMAs actually it's like
everyone in the audience I get the
Grammys they're so crazy with the
seating like if someone gets up a
million people have to rush to fill the
seat and like if they
over the crowd that kept on skating God
it was a zoo like everyone was standing
taking pictures being seats four times
that's that was I got I get social
anxiety in like crowded situations with
seven so out of concert like it's not
I'm six foot seven without heels I'm
like if I did drag and I'm over seven
feet tall
oh you must be popular yeah my mom's
like you weren't a gloomy but no so
who's your friend the makeup artist
Snooki's makeup or uh Joey Joey
thank you for upgrading her seat I got
upgraded at the VMAs complimented yes so
he texted me he was like looking for us
and he was sitting with Snooki and you
know Jersey Shore is making a big
comeback so they were really prestigious
you know and when Snooki and JWoww left
pretty early so like we took their seats
and by the way it was the most amazing
seats no this is Claudius a good friend
because so I got anxiety was like well
they're not my seats I'm tall even
sitting down I blocked people's views
yeah yeah and Vinny was behind us cutest
guy ever so I actually went back to our
seats like a little boy as Claudia's in
there it's right someone's about to
perform Claudia is such a good friend
she actually doesn't sit down and it's
like Brian's being stupid she comes back
and starts calling me as a performers on
stage and then I'm like okay you know
what I just got to do it so I ran up and
by the way how worth it was it was so
worth it oh my god and by the way just
an interesting logistical fact is that
Snooki and JWoww we're sitting in a row
in front of the entire cast like the
entire night is behind them which I just
thought was weird and then when we took
their seats I'm sure they were like whoo
yeah whatever it was so premium and it
was so every premium I might a great
time I mean is that your first like
award show
100 I'm sorry I know you been to the
Grammys no Grammys Emmys not the Oscars
I don't really I just I love music
that's my so the VMAs like I'm going
every year party if we're invited that I
think will be a Mac look attributed to
you guys yeah Kevin Teddy although we
had the worst picture together oh my god
we asked someone to take a picture for
us it's hard going there's only two
people yeah and it's hard both being
really big celebrities you know you
don't want to be seen asking for a
second of us I have to say I don't think
I have to embarrass you for a second I
literally have never seen so many people
come up to a person in my life it was
not like a traditional celebrity and
like I feel like I will go certain
places and be
relatively recognized there like you
maybe it's cuz your snow table like
everyone everyone knows you everyone has
like the utmost respect well I don't
know I mean I don't do that when to
video kinda guess on Instagram but I
have that many Instagram followers wait
I bet a restaurant in like in Chelsea
and this woman came up she's like I hear
your voice and I was like recognized by
my voice and that's weird
I said I'm so impressed thanks for
sitting on me a lot of people ahead of
me toasters I love when you're just
gonna slide into my dams I'm gay AF but
you don't give off a very gay vibe I'm
not trying to in the blazer honestly the
Blazers fixing a lot of it yeah and then
afterwards we went to the ariana grande
concert sponsored by American Express
just another interesting legit to go
back the security it was like annoying
like I understand why but like let's go
they may check my little clutch like
whatever well this happened at the
Taylor Swift concert did it they are
crazy about what I want yes no but yeah
and that's all stadiums you have to wear
a clear bag or a tiny bag it was at
Irving Plaza like it's kind of a small
venue I was just shocked at what they
said hey we're gonna take our phones but
they didn't end up doing that and then
Ariana tweeted yesterday that she's not
taking any any phones at her Amex shows
I guess they first did take people's
phones and then we're giving them back
so I just wanted to clarify clear the
error but the concert was oh yeah I love
are gonna grande what we missed cuz we
got there like five minutes early
because we went home to change our shoes
but Pete Davidson introduced her we
missed that which I really would have
liked wanted to say but whatever and we
were just like living in the back like
everyone there was like her number one
fan it was for like her real hardcore
fans and they don't all the way up the
front we were like in the back but they
did not overcrowd it so we had our own
little space by the bar obviously so I
surprised a Claudia I'd like surprises I
was like oh there's a fun yeah no I
didn't tell you what's a guess it's like
there's another fun surprising you're
like oh my god VMAs too much orientation
so much so we go and I'm also friends
with Phaedra Parks and so I introduced
Claudia and she's like I was like I know
I looked at my text next morning and I
had texted her quit being a shy dumbass
I was being I was like thank you Joe I
delivered Phaedra to you like I just
like couldn't speak I don't know why
like I've never seen I just love her I
know and like honestly I she's so
amazing I couldn't she's so amazing and
like
and gorgeous and like I just so fun so
epic and honestly like a legend in her
own right so I was nervous and like I
really don't get nervous I'm like a big
bull bond like nothing really scares me
be like Phaedra Parks it scared the [ __ ]
out of me
yeah some of my friends who are friends
with her I haven't seen houses of
Atlanta so we were like a couple
weekends ago I was like I was a
housewife historian I was I was actually
like select like choosing the epic
episodes of Phaedra I mean yeah such a
rock of them we should hold the baby I
agree that what she did was a little
shady we all make mistakes
it's bring pedra back people have done
worse and talked about Real Housewives
in New York which we'll get to later I'm
like all those ladies are doing worse
than what Phaedra did I lie Sloot's yeah
okay I feel as if we must move on
unfortunately ladies and gentlemen and
now you come to the mornin chose to
become a well-rounded millennial so here
are the fast five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast first up
is some sad news from page six if you
like page six like lives for like
tragedies not that this is necessarily
attracted me but struggling Ben Affleck
is headed back to rehab as Ben Affleck
enters rehab friends of the actor tell
page six that he's been struggling since
breaking up with longtime girlfriend
Lindsey shook us who's a writer for us
now TMZ reported Wednesday night that
the star checked into a facility after
an intervention by ex-wife Jennifer
Garner who went to Ben's specific
Palisades home Wednesday afternoon to
sit down with her estranged husband
begging him to get help so I mean this
comes as no shock if you've literally
have seen any recent photo
yesterday was him getting the box of
whiskey and then the day before was him
it in and out and like only drunk people
go to in and out this is his third stint
in rehab and I just really feel like
ever since him and Jen called it quits
his life has been tumultuous yeah
they're perfect for each other I don't
think his life will ever be right until
he gets back to me remember he wasn't he
was a family man yeah it was the best
until we knew about the tattoo yeah an
antenna that's kind of shook our world
it shook it our world they named their
kid Sarafina which is just like the best
like their feet and that's the mediocre
restaurant oh my god I never liked
people asked me like what should a
restaurant in New York I say Sarafina
it's consistently good it's like
McDonald's for elevated Italian food
that's true it's good all around I'm
actually going to plate it in like a
decade
what yeah come on up we don't like once
a week it's the best okay we'll take me
okay it didn't you
to be stable I know and there's one in
the Hamptons too right yes
East Hampton it's a food poisoning there
I throw up on the side of Montauk
Highway it was food poisoning no I swear
ready so I had lunch in his Hampton was
a rosy colored yeah yes it was but let
me explain my to lunch in his Hampton I
scarfed down a million things including
the pizza de Sophia which is like the
sandwiched pizza it's like pizza crust
truffle pizza crust it's like a sandwich
which isn't really like my my taste but
whatever i don't i don't i said i you
truffle french fries
I was trying new things and then I went
to a party in Bridgehampton and you know
I had like a weird like not just feeling
the whole time so I didn't really drink
and I was like damn I can't wait to get
home and like the girls that I was with
we're like loving the party and they
wants to say the whole girls we gotta
get home finally we're in an uber home
and I'm sitting in the front seat and
it's just things are not going well for
me in the front seat and I kindly asked
the driver to pull over and I literally
projectile vomited on the side of the
highway which is so scary because
vomiting is scary enough like what your
body can do and then the cars coming at
you and I was just like so traumatized
and now every time I smell truffle I
think a Montauk Highway
yeah where Bethenny bought her house and
renovated yeah
but Ben Affleck's back in rehab I you
know I just feel like I feel kind of sad
for him now weren't everyone made fun of
him for being cast as Batman yeah that
was like sad they're like oh you're not
masculine or smart I couldn't imagine
this hurt nay the scrutiny we have like
the smallest level yeah I feel like
you're just like universally well-liked
have you ever fallen under like huge
scrutiny so you just jinxed me no I know
I owe my god knocking about a million
times a million times yet no but you're
like a nice guy so I tried it you do
good do good work with rainbow railroad
who could eat you I don't know I
actually don't think it's possible you
said you have a good dm's like you suck
um once in a while people will say like
the charity work we do isn't good you
know like just stupid stuff but it's I
mean of a hundred interactions with
people on the internet or in real life
99 or positive
am I not like 90 of them are positive no
but you highlighted something really
important that I think everyone should
know that TPT's religious saving lives
yes you are like actually like
individual lives are being saved well
I'm not doing I'm helping you
organizations that do it yeah so Rainbow
Road is amazing so basically gay people
in 90 different countries there's only
like 190 countries and 90 them it's
still illegal to be
and many of them okay no but the were
actually the worst so I was just I just
did a secret trip to Jamaica last week
we're gonna there's gonna be a whole
national expose but people are like if
you're gay in Jamaica especially trans
people are beaten up there's like in the
culture there in the pop songs batty boy
is a term where it's like basically
[ __ ] and it's like it's used and
people that we met I met someone who had
acid burns all over their bodies oh my
god it's really really bad so think of
that you don't think so
we're just trying to raise awareness
it's not all terrible but Jamaica
there's the most amount of work Russia
is terrible there's like in Chechnya
which is more well known I I knew about
Russia so rainbow railroad we get
frequent flyer miles we've donated
hundreds of thousands of dollars we
actually get people out so if you're
being persecuted in jail like we'll get
you out we'll get you to a safe house
we'll book your flights and we get to
Haneda to America to a bunch of
different countries around the world
so rainbow railroad dot see a Canadian
charity okay if you just google the
point sky rainbow railroad book it goes
into all the details about it so anytime
I google something like travel related
you come up all the time and I'm like I
know him and it's actually super helpful
I could go stuff too because we you know
50 employees now basically and we have
30 blog post today so I don't even read
every single post half the time because
I'm just important things like toast
yeah I'm a CEO you see yeah yeah you're
she yeah I review things I don't know
well that's the president everyone
should donate that sounds awesome I mean
I can't believe the drama going on did
you make I had truly had an idea but sad
for Ben Affleck is what I was
businesslike to say and a little bit of
more happy news that I really have been
like waiting to I've been waiting to
announce this for about ten or twelve
years the Big Bang Theory is ending
after season 12 The Big Bang Theory
theory is going out with well a bang
very funny it is the 12 season
premiering Monday on CBS will be its
last CBS Warner Brothers television and
Chuck Lorre productions announced the
news in a joint statement were forever
grateful to our fans for their support
of the Big Bang Theory during the past
12 seasons we along with the cast
writers and crew are extremely
appreciative
of the show success and aim to deliver a
final season and series finale that will
bring the Big Bang Theory to an epic
creative close do you watch The Big Bang
Theory never seen an episode never see
my episode of Game of Thrones what's I
watch too many how I've literally seen
every Housewives franchise yeah being a
Bravo like I even watched Potomac you
don't watch Potomac loves to roam with
love well I don't think so I saw Andy
and I forgot to ask him yeah that's
better about asking people for Jill
Zarin this week where did you see her so
I was I saw at this tennis club in New
York we were filming something for Amex
she actually girlfriend Jill got us into
her Tennis Club Jill first of all it
looks amazing
I'm everybody slam you look so good her
boyfriend that they said Ramona didn't
is a tennis player maybe that's well so
we were filming a commercial digital
commercial for Amex and she got us in
because her boyfriend I think is on the
WTA women's tennis board Oh we were able
to film and it's like on 60th Street
these like amazing rooftop tennis courts
what if the boss the boss sees Erin oh
yeah cute I really honestly have a soft
spot but I forgot to ask Jill if she's
coming back to the house Weiss I don't
think from my inside sources I don't
believe she is my insight supposed to
say that she's coming back in a
part-time role as friend of our time I
could see that like my win the winner
got demoted to find the housewife yeah
that was tougher oh my god
Luann's Instagram last night of her
popping up do you think she's did she's
not doing her own social her social
media has been elevated in the past
couple months I think with her being in
rehab like someone else took it on and I
know that she has like a team and one
time I watched an Instagram live the
first I got the notification the second
it started so I watched and there was a
young man on it and he didn't know that
he was like on it and she was like turn
it off and then it turned off it was
like 10 seconds I was like the only
person to see it so I think that was
like her social media intern or
something taking a note I was Sonia I
actually kind of miss the days when she
was doing social media she were she
would host where it would be like she's
hosting a show she's like hello welcome
to my apartment let's go on I'm a girl
on the go and then she'd like open up
the cooler part did you see her in store
last night in a Giovanni dress yeah yes
I did
I don't I'm loving her creative for this
tour when we
so another very high-profile event that
TBG the first day let me tag along was
the cabaret with the countess and very
interesting is I had to beg borrow and
steal I was harder to get countess
cabaret tickets for one of her opening
nights and it was for the VMAs probably
good for her good for her no but we went
to the first show and what's so
interesting was the very first yes and
what's so interesting is that big
housewives um season finale they made it
seem like that was the first episode the
first show when we went the night before
and then I saw videos the next night of
sonjia's dress falling off and I was
like yeah man I wish we went to the
second one yeah but I think well Sonja
actually showed us some oh did she
Sonya was at our show she was the only
housewife because she's a part of the
shtick yeah but I don't remember I was
literally I couldn't stop drinking I
drink so much we need to show our photo
and whatever well you know what sucks is
that I need to share the photo of us and
LuAnn afterwards oh my god we were being
so Thursday like up in Luann's grill
really breach security they didn't
really we didn't really have a meeting
was like a VIP meeting great and she was
just like a lot of people weren't
breathing yeah but what's so sad about
that is that I captured so much premium
content that I planned on posting the
next day but the next day on my life was
ring and my a my show got canceled so I
never got to post that's like one of the
worst parts of this whole thing is like
I never had to put that premium content
so every now and then I'll put up the
picture of me on my Instagram story it's
like a throwback Thursday I'll get the
Thursday I'll put it on the toast
Instagram yeah oh my god big night yeah
and that's just another thing um
tbh Jesus let me tag along to I'm like a
professional plus one when it comes to
tbj
speaking of TBG our next story comes
from a very well-respected travel site
have you heard of the points guy calm
here is a little travel news I was like
to do we let you do mostly celebrity but
I'll always throw in like a business or
a trap like something more world later
to become more cosmopolitan I just feel
it's good to leave our viewers feeling
you know really uh yeah well-rounded
exactly this is the most well-rounded
morning show in mornings
soul it is going to be providing free
and discounted rides on election day did
you read this one yet I actually read it
on my way over okay
cuz I didn't realize that was hard
enough and then I read read all the
nasty comments did you see that
do you read the comments on your website
yeah
what did they say okay I'll read them
too okay so the election season
Pond us and that means it's time to
figure where and who you're going to
vote for ride-sharing company lyft won't
tell you who to put your support behind
but it does plan on making it easier for
Americans to exercise their right to
vote in November
voting in the US doesn't come easy for
everyone a recent study showed that as
many as fifteen million registered
voters didn't make it to the polls in
2016
due to transportation issues to combat
the issue ride-sharing giant lyft
announced on Thursday that it will
provide promotional codes for 50% off
rides through the polls on midterm
election day November 6 in partnership
with nonpartisan get-out-the-vote
organizations like when we all vote a
national voter registration day it will
also integrate technology into its app
to help find ones polling location that
is legit cuz it can be hard to find it
can and we don't think of it because we
live in New York and like you just
walked a couple blocks to your nearest
booth it's more like a partition but
that's not the case for everyone no good
for lyft good for left right I mean who
could who could like disagree up helping
people vote that's a good let's see what
the comments say what - oh here
lyft is based out of San Francisco need
i say more we all know that San
Francisco is not partisan if you believe
that then I have an island to sell you
Oh Jeff oh you're so funny
Jeff oh please like someone can't just
do something nice there's one of us the
celebrities behind it and then that and
it's like ghetto poor people oh my god
no this seems awesome good for let's
don't you have eat rolls oh wait oh my
god even when I never feed the trolls oh
that's what I told I know so my new
writers will like engage I'm like stop
that's what they want I know have you
ever had like a bad interaction when you
responded to a troll no really
but then it's just oh and no matter even
if your points like ah ha they're still
like oh my god he responded and that's
what they wanted of course he's not
gonna respond to the person who's like I
love I mean there's no better diss than
ignoring someone it's so true like it's
so true my cry literally said that you
last night there's nothing cooler than
like just being cool you know yeah
ignoring you remember when I said last
night yeah I'll tell you why later on my
back though your cover on TV on like the
most prestigious morning show million
people are watching um so lifts are you
which ride cherish so I know it's like
I'm like I'm barely a millennial I'm 35
new millennial so I I'm like I cut my
hab so I've only ever used uber well
also because when uber first started
doing like the referral codes
I wrote a blog post about it and then it
like Google Pagerank number one so I had
like two hundred thousand dollars in
uber credits and like from like 2015
2014 like 2017 then they changed the
rules it's only like 25 bucks I use it
as many so I had so much like uber so
I've only ever used uber I'm also like I
hate goober X cuz like I've had so many
crazy drivers don't know where they're
going like in Miami where I live part of
the time like the uber X drivers are
ratcheting like I've had two different
experiences I'm running late to the
airport they're like I need to stop and
get gas I'm like wow like you have one
job like you know what it's like in
Miami the uber is so much it's like it's
so much better it's at least better than
the taxis the taxis but it's half price
so in Miami I'll always do select
whereas anywhere I'm not always gonna be
doing su because like yeah you know and
most of the time if you just do a burr
black then it is an SUV yes good to
potentially question I've never used
lift I have this like yeah I don't know
I just so I've used lift because they
gave me a bunch of credits a while back
and then when they'll credits run out I
stopped using it but when you sign up
for lyft you have to make a profile you
have to put up a picture and I didn't
have like any cute pictures in my phone
and I had just done this funny thing on
my Instagram with like the cast members
of friends so I put a picture of David
Schwimmer as my picture and I didn't
realize that the drivers would be like
you're referencing this photo to look
for me and every time I got and only one
time was the guy like in tune with
what's necessary and like knew who Ross
was laughing about it
the other times they were so confused I
was like sorry but then I stopped using
I'm an uber patron and I get very good
customer service here because I've been
using it since high school and I do do
you think your scores over for yo I
could tell you it keeps going up I was
at a four point six seven oh yeah is it
what's yours you're reading I don't know
my dad well it's pretty good now I think
well mine was bad for a while cuz I
would give my uber account out to all my
friends cuz I'd all this free credit so
I'm like dopey friends you're using it
and like I said why is my score going
down oh yeah a bad score is not a good
reflection upon once I think I'm like I
think you really want to be four seven
four eight well I heard he could get a
little before that their stuff well if
you get below four five they said but no
all drivers are thirsty they want to
they want the money and I was they're
not gonna like not pick up a four five
yeah I lose more for a while
canceling on me then four or five is
high that's like if you a below a four I
gently didn't have that sort of grades
in school no me neither
Oh smart school I was like smart and
SATs and certain subjects but like
physics horrible like like calc like
calculus nightmares a lot of math it is
but like I like basic math so I did
really well I'm like like fundamental
math but like the conceptual like sign
like I failed the mole highway in
chemistry I'm like what's a mole right
without the conversions I would just
like store everything in my ti-83 like
all the notes I missed somebody know
we're a big believer on this show that
like being smart in school is like not a
reflection of who you are as a person
but when I got rejected from NYU and now
I have all these NYU employees did you
where did you go to college University
of Pittsburgh there's just like when
you're in high school it's like the kids
who are smart are like on an elevated
like it's like a different playing field
like you or constantly like comparing
yourself like the smart kids and like
you think you're a loser and I went to
my high school reunion and I was just
like I saw all these people who were
like the smartest it's who like
literally like they went to the best
colleges like they were like our future
you know yeah and I'm like what do you
do and she's like well you know I'm
looking for a job in fashion I'm like
what you know it's like they're all
equal now that we're not in heads going
like it's all the same like I'm very
successful and I like Laura had straight
C's yeah and had a lot of help get you
to NYU like it's like and you got
straight and you still get an Emily no
not Tracy's I had a 3 dagger keep three
four but see I went to high school in
New York and they used a lot of high
schools in New York it's like fill our
schools to like fill up the graduating
class like yes no I definitely do not
start to get to anyway yeah yeah no
totally
I was ready you went to NYU and you were
still my guest at me ma so I guess it
evens out sad sad day ok whatever [ __ ]
so good on left for being socially
conscious
I feel like ride-sharing apps are under
so much scrutiny these days Oh what are
your thoughts on this whole uber
ride-sharing Mayor DeBlasio thing and
that's happening in New York oh yeah
they're capping it I'm highly sure I
mean so I've and I live in have a house
in the Hamptons and like it was so
annoying when East Hampton passed these
dumb rules in general uber like is
convenient that's what people want like
let's stop I couldn't agree more like
it's safer people don't drive draw
like woo ber was gone in Easthampton I
knew so many people that would drive
like when they shouldn't have been so
I'm Pro uber pro all ride-sharing it is
the future like let's just like so many
people make good income off of this
situation one yeah I couldn't agree more
it's so not I mean I remember I moved to
the city in oh six and like you know
going to a happy I would be rainy you
would not get a ride home you just put
it like you would be out in the rain and
I remembering with friends like you go
on that side of the street like divide
and conquer spending 20 minutes in the
rain trying to get a taxi
hmm that doesn't exist anymore so we
changed let's not go backwards let's go
forward I couldn't do anymore
and not to mention like it's so
convenient for so many New Yorkers to
get around but then it's also literary
people's entire lives like people who
like work part-time as an uber driver
like it supplements their income so it's
like everyone is losing but know it you
know anyone to get a taxi medallion for
a million dollars all you need is a
million dollars it's so true and it's
like this is their way of like like the
taxis never got in tune with like
digital you know like when I was in
Chicago like a couple years ago and I
was using uber you could Buber a taxi
and pay for the taxi get out and he was
so great like I literally me and Ben
went to dinner I mean got out of a taxi
and we in the middle of dinner we were
like wait did we pay for that time oh no
I always I'll take a tax you know yeah
yeah but so in in Chicago we were so
used to paying for the uber is with our
uber I mean for the taxis with our uber
they'll be get out of dinner that wasn't
we got him a taxi that was it whatever
and we didn't pay and like literally
nobody said anything we realized 30
minutes later yeah that's how integrated
it was but like now in New York it's
literally the opposite and they just
they've got to evolve this is not the
way to evolve to like stop a growing
company right and like it's just it's
convenient for so many people with via
and uber pool Margot liplines literally
every day like it's just it's I can you
know but we should be using the MTA
which is in great shape right like the
bacteria on there which is new bacteria
yet to be discovered by science and so
much like I'm telling you the next bet
like I don't want to jinx it actually
microwave MSN I am obsessed with this
fourth story because it's so crazy
it's from US magazine Us Weekly whatever
but it's still true I know oh wait it's
11:11 make a wish okay that was a long
ways what are you in wish for when
not true it's along the lines of like
health happiness yeah me too okay for
like everyone I love that more so myself
just me she can't like spread it too
thin
this story is wild kendall Jenner
clarifies love magazine model comments
following controversy so another day
another kardashian-jenner controversy
earlier this week
kendall Jenner caused quite the stir
with comments that she made in an
interview with love magazine and now she
took to Twitter to rebut the criticism
so basically what she said in an
interview with love magazine in short
was quote since the beginning we've been
super selective about what shows I would
do she told the publication adding I was
never one of those girls who would do
like 30 shows a season and or whatever
the [ __ ] those girls do this caused
quite a stir on social media with many
models voicing the dismay over her in
sensitive comments model irina chernova
k-- took to Instagram to respond saying
never been so indirectly and publicly
offended in my entire life to be called
a supermodel how easy it comes to you so
basically what all these models were
saying was like you're like making fun
of us for working non-stop when like
great for you you've never had to work
non-stop and you could be quote unquote
selective with the campaigns you do and
the runways that you walk but like we're
out here living in model apartments with
30 girls sharing one room in one
bathroom and you're making fun of us and
I love the one who's like oh by the way
it's actually 70 shows a season
exactly so Jenner tweeted out an apology
yesterday that began like this I was
Miss Rose represented in a recent
interview over the weekend and it's
important to clarify in the meaning it
was intended to be entirely
complimentary but unfortunately my words
were twisted and taken out of context I
want to be clear the respect that I have
for my peers is immeasurable exclamation
point I get to experience firsthand
their tireless commitment to their work
ethic the endless days lack of sleep
separation of family and friends stress
of traveling the toll of physical and
mental health yet they still make it all
look effortless and beautiful I'm
inspired by so many of these people I
have the web page the US magazine
we got the hint though oh I need to
finish dramatically I'm inspired by so
many of the people I have had the good
fortune to work alongside there's no way
I could ever hate on that I want
everyone to win slay always what are
your thoughts I would like to give her
the benefit of the doubt you know I
obviously she's not I mean I think you
should obviously privilege and got to
where she is because
I think she I don't get the sense that
she's I don't know I say I totally
understand all the models like I'll cry
I totally mad too but of all the things
to be mad about in today's world I think
I'm gonna give her a pass on this one
yeah I feel right in the middle cuz I
definitely understand the outrage
because it's like it definitely is a
[ __ ] up thing to say and just like
totally lacking self-awareness but at
the same time I know how many ability of
magazines can be and like how really
people's words do get taken I took it
back I have a lot of friends who work
with her and say she's super hard work
ethic no diva gets it done really yes
so yeah I'm gonna give her the benefit
the doubt I don't think she actually
hates on the other ones or I think it
probably was twisted that's the Kris
Jenner and work ethic what is love
magazine it's like prestigious in
fashion digital I've never bought a copy
but they're always cool people on the
cover cool and they do that advent
calendar every year where like
everyone's naked no I definitely agree
with you that is the Kris Jenner work
ethic like regardless of their stature
Kris Jenner makes them they're never
allowed to cancel like remember when
Reggie was in the Superbowl and like
season two and Kris one Kim wants to
cancel a photo shoot and Kris but not
let her like they're not allowed to
cancel they must always be professional
and that's kind of what like just one
thing I appreciate about them is that
they really do have a hard work ethic
this is definitely a bad thing to say
but I don't know actually was twisted I
mean I can't really think she's a
putting down oh my god and having been
through that Pepsi thing she's been
through quite a few you know scam towels
so I can't think she would be that
stupid to say this yeah agreed and she
definitely said something along the
lines of being like yes I was super
selective when when launching my
modeling career which is definitely a
privilege that she had which is not a
bad thing like but I don't think she
said like whatever the [ __ ] those girls
do like I just can't think she would be
that stupid yeah agreed but maybe she
could I don't know I'm not buying it but
ever since she blurred out that Kacey
Musgraves album behind her at the Bowery
Hotel I've been a little skeptical
do you remember that I don't she took an
Instagram on one of the rooms at the
Bowery Hotel that has like the big
Terrace and behind her was a billboard
and it was for Kacey Musgraves new album
do you like his mass graves I like I
don't know I've seen her on your
Instagram yeah let's have a listening
party okay
but she blurred out the the billboard
I'm not going to Nashville today oh
she's gonna be there you can just
connect us okay good thanks cool John in
case she blurred out Kacey Musgraves
album and there's so much backlash for
it cuz like I guess she did want to
promote like an album like just like
it's a cute picture it was a very cute
billboard like it could really would it
and she went on this whole thing being
like she loves Kacey Musgraves and like
she doesn't edit her photos like I don't
know how many times and so almost like a
glare blur right yeah how many times you
gonna blame someone else you know uh-oh
just a thought our fifth and final story
which is gonna lead us into our recap of
the Real Housewives of New York episode
1 part 1 reunion Ramona Singer isn't
that proud of LuAnn de Lesseps for
leaving rehab so let's jump right in one
real housewife of New York City is
getting real about her thoughts on
co-star LuAnn de Lesseps
D'Agostino drop the Doug Encino romant
Ramona Singer romantic norm and spoke
with eanes jelly Papa dish on all the
things Real Housewives in dating related
singer hasn't spoken to del Sepp since
she left rehab but shared her opinions
on the situation when singer was first
asked if she was proud of Luann's
recovery there was a long pause quote I
think someone who gets out of rehab
after two weeks I mean are they really
well what kind of message are you
sending to other people who have serious
alcoholic problems I don't think anyone
can get better in two to three weeks
that's what Ramona said kind of harsh
but I don't disagree but I've also never
been to rehab nor they ever yet dr. red
struggled with alcohol abuse like I
don't know how long that takes
yeah just does seem like a short amount
of time so once again I also I'm not a
great Amelia but you know resource on
addiction but I do see the point in that
you know she was instagramming about her
cabaret act like the thing from talking
to friends who have been in a a and like
addiction is like putting yourself in
the same situations over and over so
when you people's places and things
right you're not supposed to put your
race plate you know if you're truly
trying to be sober like you stopped
hanging but you're drinking and I was
actually at Chris Birch's house I know
yeah so I was there I was sitting on the
sofa and how many days was that before
she went to rehab that was July 4th it
was the next weekend a week
dying and I mean so I was sitting on the
sofa and there was a whole audience and
the world's number one pianist and Chris
purchased Tory Burch's ex-husband India
to be party in the Hamptons where LuAnn
they talked about it next week LuAnn was
like definitely drunk and TPG was there
yeah and they had this pianist sorry and
so like you can walk his beautiful big
Southampton pony you can walk on the
lawn and like she walked in front of the
world's number one pianist with her hat
on like it was cringe-worthy and that's
what made him hate I was like we're like
what who just did that like you don't
walk it you can walk along the back
right there's a right it's a monster
mansion long right walk along got it so
that was a little like okay some there's
cloudy judgment then and then she didn't
Instagram story but she was like visibly
wasted in her house in Sag Harbor that
was like right as it was hot and then
everyone knew and to references that she
represented the bonfire who's on the
bonfire who's cooking Jimmy's a turkey
yeah that was bad but anyways back to
the point you know
- this whole cabaret act it's great for
her to be doing and I get people to have
creative outlets but like you probably
shouldn't be and it's like the same
situation and it's like you know she
came out and she did really well and she
looks amazing everyone's rooting for
LuAnn but then it's like you see her on
Instagram now and she's with the same
people and her convertible doing the
same thing it was like going back to Sag
Harbor which she considered up the
Belgium so I mean none of us are here
none of us are experts in therapy or
whatever but it seemed a little rushed
because it was you know from my
understanding a pretty bad interesting
you know meltdown yet so I just were
rooting for the I loved we're on Team
LuAnn and her absence at the reunion
really upset me because a I just love
her but B they really needed her like
that reunion yeah it's just what's
bizarre it's sad let's talk about that
they started in a really awkward way
because Andy was just trying to make
like pleasant conversation before
jumping into like the dirty and he was
talking about like Halloween costumes by
the way can we just talk about these
girls Andy like they're disrespect for
him his absurd and then they wonder why
he's gonna like clap back by the way
he's your boss way agree more it was the
most disorderly it's like I mean let's
just start with Carol's phone oh my god
when auntie babies I'm surprised they
even let them have their phones on set
they always keep it behind the pillows
because always yeah so actually I like
that do you remember a couple of years
ago
Ramona printed out screenshot she like
put her phone on a Xerox machine because
she didn't want a screenshot pulled it
out Jillian pulled that like a manila
envelope
oh so funny yes when Carol's phoned that
was insane to lack of respect for Annie
it's like getting out of that pallet
yeah that was like her moment do you
think that's when he made the decision
it totally she's gone
oh wait I'm sorry she she quit oh that's
what she claims yeah like yeah why would
you walk away from like literally than
I'm on to you after what ten years of
being on the show completely irrelevant
you finally get the seat next to Andy
and that's the year that you quit but
it's almost like Carole Dorinda and
Ramona like got together before I'm it's
like anytime Bethenny speaks let's all
talk at once yeah they didn't even like
regardless of whose side you're on like
this is supposed to be a conversation
and conversations go like this
one part person talks and then another
person respond it's just it was just so
petty like every time like all three of
them in unison huh
like the unison oh it's one of the
cameras that's like Oh in the biggest
contradict there's two huge hypocrisy is
going on that I must highlight the first
is that they're all ragging on Bethenny
for filming at the you know like one
they're just jealous they weren't asked
to film but there wasn't a storyline
about
crashes no there was an episode about
Ashley of course flying to London - but
oh there wasn't a story because that
would be gross no be gross
so her doing it on camera is tasteless
tacky and she's just looking for a
storyline but her being so grateful to
Dorinda off camera is not enough not
enough so she's so let's get this
straight Bethenny has to apologize on
camera in order to be in good graces for
everyone
and she has to film the funeral
off-camera just to be accepted by during
- Carole and Ramona like just the
hypocrisy like they were just
contradicting themselves they just would
not let her say one thing with and this
is regard I mean I'm so obviously like a
Bethenny
supporter but regardless of whose side
you're on just like from a human point
like you can't expect like anyone to get
anywhere without them literally letting
her speak yeah and it's just sad to see
like they clearly like had their notes
together yeah every
single thing I know they all prepare
before the reunion but it's not a good
look
I think they thought their strategy is
if they all ganged up and made it so in
tenable with Bethany they will choose
Bethany and yes totally
and they would think that the audience
just would side with the people talking
the most the most is smart yes and and
there's like 70% on Bethany side of the
watch weapons like Paul that I voted in
also the second huge hypocrisy that I
literally can't even with is like just
the apologizing for Dorinda she if
Dorinda was anyone else like they would
be anyone so hey they're bad friends
terrible friends enabling her like I
don't care whose side you're on you have
to admit that at some point like Joey is
drinking and I kind of wish Bethenny
would have just say you're a drunk you
are a drunk period the viewers know it
we know it tell us where you stab
yourself yeah you hurt people you forget
who you did suck your blood crazy things
I can't believe she apologized to the
wrong guy at the warehouse Oh Queen
indeed on camera block oh yeah you know
like it's a problem but a couple of
years ago Sonja right when Sonja was
drinking a lot people across every
reunion to bash her business and to bash
her her drinking and everyone was on
board with that but now that it's
Dorinda it's like why does Dorinda get a
free pass that like being out of control
saying crazy things and drinking a lot
where's everyone else has to apologize
for it and then we'll know but according
to Hannah I mean she did only have two
glasses of wine yeah right stupid with
her lipstick and it's like and who wipe
the lipstick off of her Bethenny I can't
believe Carole let her sit there on
camera for literally two hours without
wiping off her lipstick it was so rude I
had a lot of I've had a lot of
girlfriends like Bethenny like in high
school like the strong girl that always
wants help people that's what the weak
ones will always try to topple them it
comes down to one thing
jealousy so I mean I would be jealous
too Ramona's been on the show longer
than Bethenny and Bethenny managed to
take this little show and turn it into a
multi-million dollar business and it's
on Shark Tank she's on the cover of
Money Magazine you can't even compare
Ramona's Pinot what I will say you know
I think about that it could you know and
I get her point like I think sometimes
in life there's always going to be
people who are fakers and your group of
friends and I guess such it's not her to
be I would have just been like
congratulations like unfortunately I was
busy couldn't go to your launch but that
wouldn't make for good TV
she dug herself a digger a bigger grave
I love that I love that line and by the
way I love the noted noted I'm using
that with my secretary
no a bit like this she has to be so
careful because anything she does
they'll use as like a 30-minute argument
so like wit unless you feel really
strongly about it just like say
congratulations and say you had to hang
out Bryn or something right um but I
just want to say but then it's like if
she's fake like that or you know her
fans and viewers and we love her honesty
we love those moments so if that's what
I hate when there are housewives who
just and those are the housewives that
get kicked off because that are above it
right except for Jane she's mastered
that of being above it but like staying
relevant she kind of gets dragged into
it too sometimes once a season well she
she know she has to have her meltdown
yeah whatever she's on a boat wait the
best part is that Bethenny was right
Ramona still doesn't have a formula yeah
so it's like she threw a party four or
five months ago for a brand that doesn't
even have products vanilla or laboratory
just a name yeah
Bethenny wasn't wrong and go innocent I
loved how they were trying to come for
her with her like skinny pop products
it's in stores yeah
I'm buying Skinnygirl jeans of course I
probably can okay burgundy wine that's
what I want they're so cute they look so
gonna tell ya actually ask her I was
like are the only reason you're friends
with me so that cos Sonja was like you
have any gays in your life I was like is
this the reason why yeah but no it's the
number one so much more can we talk for
a second about Sonja Morgan New York I
have now seen Spiritist she wore this
pink number that had like a rose on it
on watch happens I've she looked
gorgeous and it was under $200 and I
didn't know 149 the dress she wore last
night can we talk about this on you
Morgan
bump it I am I was slayed by that meet
you honestly she was only one person in
the world who could pull it off
Sonja Morgan in her hey yeah she really
has come back interesting like she's
obviously lying to Bethenny mmm-hmm oh
by the way she's doing a really good job
soon Mart and they're like this season
when they were just like laughing about
her profile like that's just like me
anymore fun time no you know I've been
so good yeah this is great season but
also you don't it makes me think now
that we're seeing a clear sober skinny
fit awesome Sonya yeah it's like this
must be but did you think she was sober
when we saw her
countess cabaret I thought she was black
out but I also think that might be her
stick no but I think she probably was
drinking but I'm in sober in the sense
that like she's not drinking all the
time yeah she's not an alcoholic she can
drink it's not but just like cutting
back it definitely has helped her just
be more lucid and more clear I've never
been to her Wednesday night parties who
out here what toaster can get me total I
mean have we got it putting it out into
the universe I need to go oh she ran it
up oh I'll host her Wednesday night game
mixer at my partner I can fit a lot of
total it's a great apartment wait I just
have to putting it down Gompers it's
almost like the Sonia we're seeing now
is the Sonia that JPMorgan fell in love
with totally you know she was like this
gorgeous glamorous funny cool collected
girl who like was traveling all around
the world and that that lifestyle
definitely got her and she kind of like
fell from grace yeah and when we first
saw her on the show she was like picking
up the pieces I feel the same way with
the countess but you know the count the
count didn't fall in love countess knows
the jokes about her now yeah and that's
the best
but yes Sonja and she wasn't that
delusional this year no she was so on
the ball like and like anything when
Carol came to her room and carta henna
and like they were just talking she was
being so rational like I'm just I'm
endlessly surprised by the new Sonja
Morgan yeah I'm loving it except she and
like they had to get so many subtitles
in the reunion last night because
everyone wouldn't stop talking when they
play those clips they usually have the
clip on the screen and then the
Housewives reaction in the corner they
swapped it because there was so much
drama happening when they were playing
the kids Dorinda let's go back to Andy
again to like his side I owe you could
just did you could tell Andy was not
having it with Dorinda and Carole but
yeah you know former HR professional
like read your audience like this is
your boss like yep and did Carol
actually say that you're full of [ __ ]
Andy she didn't say it but she says it
but they played it somewhere so full of
shot was Elizabeth dumb dumb dumb dumb
dumb dumb dumb but also with Andy it's
like he's getting a ton of [ __ ] for um
they some Twitter people are saying like
he took Bethenny's alright and he
intervened twice once when he said that
that Jill reached out to production to
throw the funeral cuz that's a really
important to stick so that's not taking
sides that's literature whole narrative
is Bethenny's a fake person he wants to
to film and Auntie has information like
that sets the record straight and it's
really important that so I didn't think
that was taking about them inside it was
just a fact that proved Bethany wasn't
lying and bet things just sitting there
like and he also intervened when he was
like let her talk and that's not
necessarily taking definite Ike no one
would let her talk everyone else when
they got a moment to speak except in
Slate literally and say word the know
one word she's so like irrelevant
although I do like her new haircut meet
you I didn't like her dress but I feel
like the show has really brought her
back that like she knows how valuable it
is since Lee the Cameron do you mean
Cameron from Delos oh no no no Cameron
is the absolute worst I like Tinsley I'm
getting slowly over her her trying on
wedding dresses okay
taking care outside but now that Carol's
gone I think Tinsley values this show so
much as like a job and a formula don't
come and like I celebrate like a status
thing that she might I did like Tinsley
Tinsley's dropped to the floor when
Scott walked in that was a good moment
and I think then bringing out her on the
show was like the perfect cuz I don't
like when like celebrities come on the
show like Denise Richards like you know
I really like but Rena has been probably
one of the best but that's so famous
before that [ __ ] was Richards no but
she's a household name I don't really
know who Lisa Rinna was a household I
mean oh yeah okay well then maybe but
Tinsley was a perfect cast because she
was the original like what they were
social I was like and she needed the
show and I'm just like endlessly
disappointed by her presence on the show
you think Tinsley shook with Carol
leaving like how do you think the
alliances are gonna shift next season so
that's what I'm saying I think Tinsley
knows the value of the show and knows
that it could spend maintenance leave
gonna try to get I don't think Bethenny
would want to no no no but she's
definitely does and the Carol's of the
world because she's seeing the audience
reaction and really the audience
dictates who leaves right like if
someone hates everyone and no one liked
the on II like they listen to the
audience which I love like having to say
that's why I feel like I need to come on
the show and preach that we can get the
people off that we want off you know I
just feel like it was so pointless and
they never got to the end of any
argument and they never let Bethany
speak and I'm just like I'm so done like
I can't I can't leave we have two more
usually the more I know usually the
first installment is like relatively
boring because they saved
yeah there was no recaps of the season
really right it was just like we didn't
get anywhere no we didn't move forward
we didn't move the needle like other
different I love their montage in the
fashion meet you that acid party in the
Hamptons when they were a whole that was
so funny it has been such a long season
that I didn't remember Halloween no I'm
sorry
Luann's costume I have to be on with
Carol they all tone-deaf and they all
knew it yeah and because none of them
said anything they did want to look like
[ __ ] so they said that you're trying
to save face no it was bad like when she
came in I was I didn't know what to be
more shocked by the Afro or the
blackface I was like yeah look that is
just rule number one like it's not black
taste it's caramel face no they're like
she's got a spray tan no in an afro oh
so bad on so many levels that like I
couldn't believe actually I mean I knew
Carol was be gonna be the one to say it
but she was the only one who really gave
justice for LuAnn because that was like
not cute at all any other thoughts on
the real houses New Yorker you didn't
I'm just like I'm so living for this and
I would like to make a formal
announcement I would like to invite
Bethenny to my home with my sister's
first about dinner because as a fellow
Jew I just Inc she would have a good
time we make really good food we're fun
she's Jewish Frankel yeah what she's
she's like hat I think hurt no I think
sure no she's not Jewish and definitely
I'm practicing no not practicing but
Cooper's Jewish and her mother was a
Roman Catholic yeah she's half Jewish
not the right house okay all right
whatever I just I want to invite her to
my house because I feel so strong I
can't believe I've come so far cuz like
when Bethenny burst jail I was like team
Jill in high school because I like loved
Jill but now it's like an adult I kind
of watching the footage back and how Jo
rebuffed her bad move like don't these
people realize come for Bethenny it's
not gonna work out well for today you
should play more of that footage because
when Ramona said the mop Ramona's so
thirsty Ramona's always pretending she
wants people to get back together like
Carole and Anthony and Bethenny and Jill
but she doesn't she's just such a thirst
monster that so you don't you don't
believe Ramona's a woman supporting one
that whole thing it's like what okay so
that thing has to support you even
though you're a [ __ ] and don't have no
businesses like what could you do a
vagina but you have 30 friends you can
scramble in a heartbeat did you hear
what
I [ __ ] love I actually found out good
gossip about Dorinda and Ramona because
jorinda really does run in this very
elite Richie or crowd because of her
ex-husband and Ramona is like her trashy
friend interesting but I don't take
jorinda for like rich and fancy but the
apartment is like so sad and like ha ha
I just her house in birches is really
pretty but like I just don't take and
she's a drunk we just have to because I
know we have to go to Dallas but like we
the crab client incident I know I know
okay look there's literally too much
going on like I can't even like the one
hour show it's not enough I cannot wait
for part 2 and part 3 like it's I think
this is gonna be maybe even better or on
par with seasons of Housewives scary
Island yeah pretty up st. Barths with
Aviva
you two are white trash quite frankly I
can't leave how far Sonja and Ramona
have come like they are not friends I
know and they are like digging at each
other it's because Sonja got clear yeah
I'm real wait and find out thing on New
York do you think they should allow
LuAnn to come back I think the show's
bad for her right well here's the thing
they haven't started talking about car
to Hannah yet and all the girls were so
mean to LuAnn when she was really on a
good and righteous path and now that
she's acting we have like they they're
justified in being mean to her but like
but even the first day back from rehab
when they were all drinking wine around
her like I couldn't agree more like and
how do you like really heal when you're
just being put in the same situations
that drive you crazy and this show does
drive people crazy
it drives you to drink I never thought
it would she's such like a hot topic now
I don't think they would let her go like
from a TV rating standpoint no but put
ratings aside ethics I don't I mean
that's why they fired Phaedra ethics
because she did something so horrible
that like what did she do again she
keeps candy if I try to rape her is that
it yeah I don't follow
yeah I like Atlanta to a tee but then
when all that happened a like had to
catch up yeah she basically if you stop
trying to date rape yeah like there is
yeah Porsha that she had told her she
would date rape or so or something like
it was it was like he's dead it was it
was not good that's not good I mean
that's not that's I think worse than all
of this but like I feel like Andy really
only intervenes in reunions when things
are so would like ethics and look
morally corrupt
snick and that's what I feel like
happened last night yeah it's so not
right what because the thing is the show
is like Ramona
it's like 63 like what is all this
housewife yeah Ramona's not the future
of the show like there's very few I mean
not to be ageist and sexist and
everything but like just looking at show
business if there's Ramona's not gonna
anchor this show into the next five
years and she's not that used to be like
cute and funny like the singer singer
like Ramona coaster but her shtick is
getting old really and it's all very
contrived like even her like delivery
and when she waters away like you are
not I that was the best oh my god I
literally like that is my go-to wow wow
wow that's the best and you know I have
trouble like separating reality from
reality TV because like when you live in
New York and you have a lot of Instagram
follower it's like you meet housewives
like and like I have had lunch with
Carole and like when you speak like
pretty good friends and I got my turn
holiday party I'm like I really liked
her
and I still really do and it's like
awkward because I'm like I know Carole
and then I know Carole on the show yeah
and it's like they're two different
people because I'm Carole can hey yeah
that show does make you crazy
but the Carole on the show I'm like not
here for so like how do you exist in
this in between much like work though
the thing is these people are not in
really friends no and that's why every
time they start the new season they're
like how was your summer cuz it'll
[ __ ] yeah but I really accept this
whole Greek moment with Ramona and Kelly
dah each other that honestly Vicki
Gunvalson Kelly Dodd and Ramona Singer
is the scariest thing of all time I mean
I'm a Vicki you're a Vicki apologist oh
my gosh I'm kind of her but I know you
like her she's nuts whatever okay now
we're gonna do some TPG related
questions i source them from facebook
but if you're watching i also the
YouTube stream up here so feel free to
drop a comment about points about credit
cards about anything about career about
whatever add it up we got really
specific questions and I'm gonna start
beating them just you you rattle them
off okay this is some christie span just
start off how did you fall into the
square so i and you add the Taking
Chances part cuz that's my favorite part
of the story
okay Celine Dion is a part of the story
so I got into sorta look the camera look
to you a little bit about its story
journey
what's my name oh no Christina Oh Chris
Cristi so very long story short like
I've always been like a computer geek
dork like when I was 12 I was a computer
whiz in my house my dad traveled a lot
for work one day he's like we have all
these frequent flyer miles and I figured
out a way to use them so we went on
vacation to the Cayman Islands like my
family of six for free it was crazy like
this is so my dad traveled a lot like
would miss my basketball games it was
sad of course she played basketball and
then in college I became student body
president and would start like and
studied abroad so often I traveled a
bunch and I got elite status and I
googled what the US Airways okay our IP
so I googled then and then discover that
there's this whole community people like
this subgroup of weird people that like
maximize frequent flyer miles so I got
into that was 2004 and then started
working on Wall Street traveled a lot
for work
I made no money cuz I was in HR during
the recession but all of a sudden I had
like millions of points anyway I
literally was like two thousand dollars
in credit card debt but I was able to
fly first-class everywhere so I go all
my friends were like you want a trust
fund
yadda yadda yadda start a blog in 2010
from my cubicle I'm just like doing one
blog post a day travel this what I love
people start reading it and then the
credit card companies in 2011 were like
my friend worked for like an advertising
agency and was like they know about your
site and they love what you're writing
and you're you know sending people to
Amex calm and we'll pay you to do that
so I was like what right and literally
within a month and then the New York
Times heard about me and I interviewed
so I learned how to do press to drive
traffic and it was like this perfect
storm and in April of 2011 and I the
money started to really come in and but
everyone's like you can't leave Morgan
Stanley if you're gonna be a VP you're
27 years old my you know everyone's like
you're crazy
yeah and then so I was listening to
Celine Dion so I'm a huge Celine Dion
fan it's called taking chances on my way
to work and it's about jumping off a
ledge not knowing what's below chance
taking chances watch the video on
YouTube which we do around midnight
every time we think it's really good to
taking chances so anyway quit my job and
then it's just been since 2011 you know
adding employees I sold the company got
sold again and we're now we're like
around 50 full-time Wow and a couple
different offices and then we have even
more contributors who write for the site
so it's really really fun so cool it's
so impressive and I'm endlessly
impressed by just like you and your
business because I went to a talk you
did in Montauk at the surf Lodge and it
was just like a general like Q&A talking
about let's rosario Dawson
oh yeah rosario dawson showed up those
so cool it was her favorite oh she's so
beautiful and I was just like so
impressed cuz like I'm just like
learning new things about your business
all the time and you were just like so
funny and charismatic about like
something that could be like relatively
boring I'm like money and I just I just
think they're so great and I just want
everyone to know like the TPG that I
know this is from Britt Lopez I've only
started using a credit card a year ago
do you think I'll be a cruise approved
for the Chase Sapphire yes so that's a
great question Britt Britt yes so a lot
of people as long as you don't have
anything negative as long as you don't
miss a payment as long as you haven't
you know skipped out on a bill which I
did once in college and it haunted me
for like eight years so Jay check your
credit score it's free to do there's
tons of free sites that all fight go is
the score you want to check though
a lot of credit cards give it to you for
free if you google how to get a free
FICO score our post will come up but
understand your score as long as you're
like you know a lot of people even if
you know tons of credit like even 680
and up will get you most credit cards
people think you need to have this like
800 score and a 200000
it's pretty easy so it's like at 850 I'm
like 780 I mean it fluctuates because I
put so much spend every month and it
goes up and down but as long as you're
over 700 you can pretty much get at any
credit card okay but before beginner
cards you can get you know like the
Chase Freedom Card is one of the kind of
no annual fee beginner cards the cool
thing about that is once your freedom
unlimited it's probably the better one
but once you get in with Chase they have
all the best cards so build a
relationship off with like a freedom and
then if you do get a sapphire once you
build up your relationship with them you
can actually take your freedom points
which are supposed to be cashback but if
you get a Sapphire Preferred you can
then transfer those cashback points into
your sapphire account and then use them
for more value or transfer them so so
yeah but you know what is interesting
the last time you were here that I think
is important is you will not like you
don't do like sponsorships in the sense
like
won't promote a credit card because
someone's paying you notice every only
one hotel yes
so our business model so we make all of
our money pretty much so if you get a
credit card through the points guy calm
so we get a commission right right and
so that's how I use to pay my writers
and everything but we only promote the
best offer in the market and there are a
lot of bad credit cards out there we
won't touch it so on our top deals like
it's only products that we promote the
thing is there's no one best product for
everyone like it depends on whether you
want to fly first-class you just want
cash back you know there's a look at
your life and what you want to do a lot
of times you know especially if you're a
young millennial in the city like
getting a couple dollars cash back like
makes the difference I don't care about
Mykonos that'll be next year what I get
so whether you want cash back you know
but there's a bunch of cards out there
you know they have no annual fee that
gives there's this Wells Fargo propel
card no annual fees and we'll link all
this video $300 and free you get $300 in
cash back just for getting it and then
you get triple points on you know dining
gas groceries and even streaming
services like Netflix so the first ever
card that does on all the streaming
platforms but what's called Wells Fargo
propel alright good to know um a lot of
people ask if you think it's better like
there's a myth that should you pay your
credit card balance in fall under
percent in fall early thousand percent
you if you're paying APR interest you're
gonna be losing all the point value that
you get so 100 percent if you can't pay
your bill if you can on-time info and
and even if you can before you know just
to pay it off cuz you still get the
points even if you pay it off early so a
hundred thousand percent do not get in
credit card debt if you're in credit
card debt don't worry about points just
put a laser focus plan to get the credit
card debt down because it's like
quicksand I mean I was excited card debt
out of college I moved to New York I was
you know didn't realize the concept of
like one paycheck going to run right and
one you know so it's sad because I had
to learn budgeting the hard way I should
really teach it in school totally but
but you're a big fan of like not really
investing in like points and redeeming
until you're financially until you're
financially
yeah or like you're in a good place yes
but the thing is we have a lot of
college kids that read this site that
you know you can get these credit card
signup bonuses are huge
and fly for free I mean so your trips
can be very very cheap if you're getting
your hotel in flight for free and so
there's we have a whole budget traveler
column now on the site we've got up we
just teamed up with the cycle mommy
points so for young families there's all
different strategies for different types
of people it's not just for people it's
not one for exactly this is from Kelsey
Goddard warden what's the best airline
and hotel to redeem my Chase Sapphire
Reserve points up in general chase
points are best redeemed when you
transfer to United low fees pretty good
rates and then for hotels United or
chase - hi it hi hi okay yeah so if you
transfer to higher tech for example
25,000 points to stay at the Park Hyatt
Maldives which is like $1,000 a night
hotel so the thing with points is it's
all math so 25,000 points is getting
away thousand dollars in value that
means each point is worth four cents in
value okay it's 25,000 times four is it
yes so that's when you really have to
start thing about math wise so think
about if you have to chase sapphire
reserve you're earning three points per
dollar on travel and dining and each of
those points is worth four cents when
you go to redeem it and that's pretty
high you're not always gonna get that
high but you can get that high
transferring to partners that you're
getting like a 12% return on all of your
travel and dining that's an insane
rebate especially you thing about how
much you start spending on uber and
everything so the goal of points is to
get credit cards that give you maximum
points and all the categories that you
spend so whether it's streaming or uber
groceries gas there are cards out there
and you know there are if you google
literally the best credit card for
groceries the points guy we our team
constantly analyzes write best card for
cash backs like what you spend your
money on it's fun your money amount and
where you want to go with those points
or if you just want cash and cash back
is it skating cash is king Shana
Stillman what is the best airline
specific credit card like do you
recommend like the Delta MN the way I
would say this is each of the programs
each airline has a different program I
think in general United miles are the
most valuable because they allow you to
redeem on Star Alliance is the biggest
Alliance so when you're thinking about
airlines you should also understand
their partners so you know but so
basically Delta is a
really good airline to fly but they're
miles are the least valuable because
Delta's Delta's naughty so for example
like United you can redeem 115,000
points to go to Europe
round-trip business class okay Delta
yeah we'll be like 200,000 in coach
right so all of these points are I mean
you can get deals on Delta but they're
much harder to use
Delta's my favorite I know so this is
where you always have to balance out
right plot points everywhere collect
points everywhere so that's why you can
fly Delta and enjoy Delta but have a
Chase Sapphire reserve or preferred so
that you can transfer to United so if
you want to go to Greece on Lufthansa
right you have options the point is you
don't want to put all of your miles on
American Airlines right like Delta also
has bad partner Airlines because anytime
I find something that's not Delta I
always see if I show ya Delta I did this
like so I like international first-class
Delta bands it so Air France Korean
China Eastern they all have these
amazing first-class products but Delta
bands it you can only fly up to business
class and Delta charges more for
business class for international warts
in general than American does for first
class on their partners so you know
first class Cathay Pacific is like 220
thousand miles to go to New York to Hong
Kong round-trip and Delta and business
class is like 350 400 so understand each
program has its quirks but Delta also
does have other coach Awards which can
make sense so it's not I love
international first-class travel
not the program for me well okay so but
I'm flying Delta today because it was
the best time right but so for me who's
like I really traveled within the United
States most like 90 percent of the time
especially for the tour and I have been
flying Delta and collecting the points
because I'm not paying for the flight
but what do you think is the best like
inter-american flight like a United
Delta American like up just like the one
at the end of the day all of the
carriers are like when you're flying
just like regional they're all roughly
the same I mean JetBlue if you're fine
coach JetBlue is by far you're gonna get
free Wi-Fi that's fast you can watch
YouTube you know all the others charge
for shitty slow Wi-Fi so is my
enemy nemesis marbles Rock gouging 40 40
bucks for dial-up speed internet whereas
I'm Jeff blue you may pay a little bit
more but I'm 6-7 if--like I flew coach
last week on JetBlue bags around I said
an exit Roman and I'm at Eve and I buy a
seat next to me so I don't have to said
anyone but that is cheaper than flying
first-class and I have more space so a
JetBlue mint if you fly across the
country it's the best business class you
can did you get the suite we can close
the door so it's like two one to one but
it was my first time flying mint so I
didn't know I had to hit the one yeah
and then I was like so like sleeping so
close to this guy
yeah but the food's delicious
but it's you know they don't fly
everywhere so I think in general all the
US carriers are roughly the same but it
JetBlue's a Southwest so it's like you
know nitty gritty but you know they're
on time they're easy program what is the
most delayed airline I think you've
experienced it's funny enough I think
JetBlue has had some pretty big issues
you know out of New York
everyone's delayed because our air
traffic is horrible so you know a rain
cloud comes in and everything gets in
disarray
I think the stat Delta's I think the
best performance-wise Delta United
American JetBlue would probably be Oh
interesting
so Danielle Kat wants to know how many
credit cards do you have
it's funny I think I have 25 credit
cards it's an interesting perk working
at the points guy it's kind of what I've
had for years is all of your annual fees
get paid for so everyone in my office
has a platinum carcass of 550 we pay for
much so we are hiring at the points guy
always my next question I saw that
actually I was I was creeping on the
comments hold on Abigail pew pew do you
need to hire an assistant she wants big
for you but what are you hiring so my
assistant is a job that I used to burn
through an assistant like every other
day it's my schedule is insane the
logistics so my assistant I've had four
years and he's not even assistant he's
my chief of staff some extremely but
what are hiring for so we're always
hiring for writers social media we're
hiring right now for social media editor
I need someone with several years of
social media experience I would love
platform experts like Instagram not we
need to launch more on Pinterest
snapchat we've given up on as if you're
working at an agency snapchat they tell
we are coming up with better advertiser
tools LinkedIn like if you've ever built
a brand on LinkedIn that's very valuable
to me
okay we're always looking for writers
well plus the link business analyst and
generally all in New York yeah okay got
it
Heidi Thatcher rafter what would you do
it with 300,000 Amex points 300,000 Amex
points so a.m. explains in general are
not good for transferring to hotels so
transfer them to Airlines I would
transfer Amex and it once again if you
google the best ways to use Amex points
it'll be like 20 different options
depending on what you want the points
comm is the first yeah of course I love
flying move tons of first-class and if
you transfer 90,000 to Aeroplan which is
a Air Canada's program you can fly
Lufthansa first-class to Europe and it's
amazing caviar the whole nine so well so
that is the number one thing I learned
from you is that like let's say you want
to take a first-class flight somewhere
and I forget what the airline is and
it's like $5,000 or no no sorry it was
ten I remember but you said to buy the
miles on Alaska airline and then
transfer those to the airline your
servers lied so buying miles can make a
lot of sense so Alaska Airlines right
now this yeah right now Alaska Airlines
is selling miles let's just say their
two cents a piece to buy so Alaska will
allow you to fly New York to Hong Kong
on their partner cafe for 50,000 miles
it's crazy it's one way business class
50,000 well so if you buy Alaska mile is
a two cents apiece you can redeem on
cafe 50,000 it's $1,000 to fly New York
to Hong Kong 15 hours in business
classes I can $10,000 ticket so there
can come a point but of course you got
to know the rules
Cathay flights don't show on Alaska so
you have to call the book so there is
some a little bit of research you have
to do so I don't recommend buying miles
speculatively and then hoping to use
them make sure there's availability but
there's ways that you can buy miles and
then pay like less than what coach would
cost it's so crazy we actually have a
post yesterday actually a British
Airways coach review and one of our
writers you can use British Airways
miles which Amex transferred a British
even fly
coach it was like $350 versus a thow
they were charging 1801 way last minute
so even if you fly coach miles can save
you tons of money well so that was a
question from Lauren and McHugh does it
make sense to buy extra airline miles
for every airline yeah so in general
don't buy extra miles and when you're at
the kiosk just checking in they give you
horrible rates always check the points
guy like if there's a deal like all the
airline's run deals throughout the year
like 50% on a sale on
there's always sales on points so never
buy a full price so and you can Google
like if if you know United mile sale
you'll see like the last one or if
there's a current one on our site
usually that's far they usually a month
or so but the airline's always go back
and forth right yeah
are there any airlines this from Lucy
Danks any airlines you would never fly
Lucy I would never fly no I mean I'll
fly whatever gets me somewhere I fly
Brian air within Europe because a lot of
times they fly random little flights and
honestly an exit row an economy you know
that's the thing flying the cheap
carriers like spirit and one's like the
worst the worst they charge they're so
cheap though so if you just pay the $30
for priority boarding and the best seat
on the plane just don't buy the cheapest
ticket on a ratchet carrier and then
expect the world like so buy the cheap
ticket cough up a couple bucks and then
fees
the thing is they treat you like a king
like Ryanair if you try to board that
plane and you didn't pay that four
pounds to do it they will like Club you
like Nancy Kerrigan like so like no one
ever buys it so like if you spend $10
you're a king so I wouldn't fly carriers
like Cubana the airline that just
crashed in Cuba that like the really bad
safety ones definitely but um this is
from Ally
mahadji Eyre who is one of my favorite
toasters um where do you consider home I
see you're always flying everywhere and
I see your beautiful houses where do you
feel most at home well New York is our
office I have lived in Miami for a while
for the last several years splitting my
time I think I still love Miami but like
New York is becoming more and more
that's where all my offices and I'm here
more and it's closed in the Hamptons but
my family's from I grew up in Doylestown
Bucks County so I had a house it's a New
Hope which is beautiful any of my Bucks
County toasters oh yeah they exist
Kendyl I sell what's the worst hotel you
stayed at like your grossest story or
the worst flight experience you guys so
the craziest hotel I was staying
I had the penthouse booked at the
Renaissance Philly Airport I took my
nieces and nephews to a Phillies game or
Eagles game I had to go 5 a.m. flight so
I went to the Renaissance like there was
a convention in town and everything was
sold out and if hotels will give you a
room away if you come in late so after
the Eagles game dude yeah crazy semester
oh yes oh if you're gonna like check-in
at midnight oh wait and you know the
city's sold out always called I even
called ahead and told them I was gonna
be in at midnight they still gave my
room Oy I did it Facebook live in the
lobby that went viral and then Marriott
people were freaking out I pay for all
my own travel right back to that so I
pay for all their own travel I never let
hotels know when I'm coming I don't want
special treatment yeah you fly I want to
experience what my readers would
experience that's gonna be harder these
days so that's why I don't do tons of
reviews but but anyway so they ended up
giving me a room that someone had slept
in and I go in and it was dirty and
there was like weave hair weave on the
floor I mean it made for an amazing
Facebook live so where's Google like the
points guy Facebook live Renaissance
Philly Airport what is the most
expensive ticket you've like see you've
sat in so I bought Etsy hod which is a
one of the amazing middle-eastern
carriers based out of Abu Dhabi they
have what's called the residence and so
I was the first class
so you get your own bedroom on a plane
not only to get your own bedroom a
double bed fancy Linens
you get your own shower and bathroom
your own no one else could touch it you
can't fit in an average shower and on
the planes the a380s actually have
really big ceilings it doesn't pass the
TV do shower tests but it's like close
enough and you're in the shower at
39,000 feet
you complain so you got your own bedroom
shower your own Butler and your own
living room and a door that closes and
it's 33,000 one-way dollars and if you
google the point sky
Etihad residence there's a YouTube I had
a camera crew along of course
caviar what does the plane look like is
there coach in that plane too I don't
know
yes so there's a residents first class
business class and coach and it's a
double-decker there's one per plane just
one yeah so it's like they've lowered
the prices now and it's just for two
people so it's like it's like
grand New York maybe 25 certain
provinces well princess have their own
like tricked-out private planes points
princes yeah yeah points princesses
rasie how many airplanes have you been
on that have showers in them I'm so
really only a tea HOD and Emirates are
the really the only ones with showers
unfortunately so I try to fly them
whenever taking a shower after like five
glasses of Dom it's hard it's so fun
like I put my music on and on an
Emirates the floors are heated it's a
huge bathroom you can sit down and do
your makeup although one time I was in
the shower like fully naked and like the
turbulence over go in the Capitol's
please return yours here right now so I
like the first split second I was like
do I just put my towel around me I go to
my seat or like I like I well I always
bring shorts and like a Loulou t-shirt
with me so I like to through it I'm real
quick and was like and it was like
bumping up and down they let me take
another shower that's nice do they limit
the time that you can use matter it's
like six minutes you can ask for more
but it like six minutes it's like long
enough for like a nice like quick little
did you hear about the baby fetus I was
found in a yes yeah it was a baby fetus
in an airline toilet like who left it
there I don't know I know we actually
wrote that story and I saw it on my of a
screen that shows all of our top stories
I was like I care not to I don't know
the detail I didn't read that one that's
so disgusting so leave us with a final
thought when it comes fusing points when
it comes to you know and spending the
least on on travel what is your number
one like sage advice so I would say you
know get a bunch of public get points in
different programs actually my number
one tip would be set a goal right if
this all become so confusing I know a
lot of people I know be like oh my god
it's so confusing what do I like set a
goal you know I want to go to Hawaii I
want to go here and then work back from
there like look at and so I'll leave
this fall we're launching the TPG app
which is gonna allow you to track your
points set a goal and then use your
points column one as well as tell you
the credit card you should be using etc
it's a lot right now of like manual
labor but I'll leave what points are
currency unlike Bitcoin that goes up and
down like crazy everyday points or a
currency that the more you mind your own
knowledge like the more blog posts you
read of ours
the more valuable they come right so
and it's insane there's no other country
in the world like there are 50,000
60,000 a hundred thousand points signup
bonuses the banks will give you
literally a thousand dollars for getting
a credit card so it's insane yeah it's
not too good to be true as long as your
credits good and you pay them off on
time one or two credit cards a year you
could be going on a free trip every year
so not just get the sign-up bonus but
look at every single dollar you spend
get a credit card that's gonna give you
a bonus for that bonus out there there's
several everything depends there's some
airline cards there's like a bunch at
offer a hundred thousand points Oh
Google the points guy hundred thousand
point credit card signups and but my
biggest tip is so I'm the points guy but
you can follow me on instagram at brian
calley okay there's three famous Brian
the RIAA and kely the one half of
Florida Georgia line his name with Brian
Kelly and he wrote the song written by
Mason Ramsey I mean saying Mason Ramsey
there's a very popular football coach is
that what he is Notre Dame yeah and then
there's T BJ it's hard competing for
those Google search results both so make
sure to follow at the points guy on
Instagram and Brian Kelly on Instagram
premium content delivered on both thank
you for being here sharing your tips
sorry I was late I actually was having a
fashion emergency I have this baby blue
suit so I was gonna wear baby blue for
Bru I didn't get a chance to talk about
Dallas Klan lock-ins weave the red
peppers terrible oh my god neither rim
meat is so terrible well you know what
we'll discuss at another time
guys thank you so much for watching
we're gonna link a bunch of what Brian
said in case you're confused like me
just to help you know clear some of the
air but thank you guys for listening
reminder there is no show tomorrow
because I'm gonna be tired and that's it
thanks for tuning in to the morning test
make sure you follow us subscribe to us
YouTube Facebook and the podcast app we
will see you on Monday I have a great
weekend safe travels safe travels
you